Oh
[Music]
so guys Wednesday morning heading into
the office bunch of early meetings bunch
of uh updates on people's businesses so
meeting with the leaders creative and
and account strategy leaders of
different business units so that should
be fun looking forward to that and just
some new business meetings client stuff
should be a pretty busy day another just
kind of like you know it's that classic
nondescript
oh is this up as a few hundred come on
your run great I love it I love
yesterday being 200 just nothing crazy
right we can even talk about it
thank you know you and I didn't oh I was
Tyler that's the punchline that's
actually actually that was even better
like like I was about to say classic 197
or 202 you know nondescript episode that
nobody will really remember 13 years
from now and that's the kind of point
and that almost even speaks to episode
200 obviously in YouTube culture and
social media culture when people hit
5,000 fans or 10,000 fans or 50,000 fans
or a million fans or or episode 200 you
know I mean I've done that with the Wine
Library TV thing but since this is more
of a documentation this is the grind I
mean I think it's kind of um actually
pretty fired up that we didn't even
reference episode 200 yesterday that's
exerts what we're doing here right just
you know grinding documenting over
creating living the CEO entrepreneur
life trucking alone making things happen
which is very much on my mind a very in
operations mode right now very focused
on making vaynermedia efficient faster
better stronger meaner leaner
and all those things so
[Music]
I got this offsetting uncomfortable
energy on my mind I've been at this 7
here to watch family fall behind I'm
losing touch with my baby I'm growing
going to back I'm thinking that's about
others should I reach out to my dad he
missed my whole childhood who's really
the victim when I get rich I'll fly him
out they say the three-year-old miss
them I never knew him as a man and I am
prepared to die I just wanted cautious
in every case we me in the sack we won't
be bothering son although we love just
the life as ever friendship man to man
it just catch up on his life it's crazy
crazy things a lot of nonsensical
feelings can haunt you just know that if
I bring up the past it's not it's on you
it never was well maybe before but now
I'm truly happy in IMAX imager I
understand things happening install them
either way I'm a prodigy youngest
missions that begins in a day it's not a
time it's not a dress it's not a sailing
garrison site it's not amazing it's not
here's what if they get me now tell me
now is not a time it's not a placement
it's not it's easy defecate it's not
amazing it's not a happy hit so what if
they've getting me now me now if I told
you all the things I was on my mind so Y
all the things I was know my mind how to
pay that was on my mind you go right
crazy right hey yeah I know my vision
ain't blood but I was raised by the
radio where moms Bronco with selling
Slim Shady DMX
did he say it's a [ __ ] got me through
some dark times I'm feeling went through
it with me I guess - full circle dad -
blaming directed in your direction
I never stopped and blame some
neglection are blamed nothing on the day
things happen so well I thank God
everything I love how everything fell I
love how everything fair that when the
struggle is real I love when people are
faced the excuses they make that when
they say I ain't great dope we now make
a mistake lovely they love when they
shot me but love it most when they hate
sometimes tough to look yourself in the
mirror me as a CEO look at myself in the
mirror realizing you're not allowed to
be a little slower than I wanted two
things like that it's always interesting
I like I said an executive yesterday
look it's just complaining that you're
down 40 nothing in the first quarter the
games already over you need to think
about the legacy behind coming back from
40 nothing and so that's where I'm at
where does destiny stuff is crazy leave
me thinking I am so wrote this song last
week and guess who hit me out the blue I
was gonna ask my sister Ashley if she
could get in touch then I received a
voicemail for my father man life is nuts
I'm convinced
everything happens all for reasons spoke
to my daddy got caught up on a couple of
seasons good thing that was on my mind
so y'all the days I was know my mind
so y'all today that was on my heart you
go crazy crazy crazy
[Music]